and Oklahoma is a unique space in terms
of the number of african-american towns
that were established some suggest
upwards of 50 African American towns
between 1924 and 1928 Reverend as is
Joan who's going around documenting this
sort of self determined vibrant
african-american communities you see the
african-american educators doctors
lawyers land owners oil barons and I
think that's what's so remarkable about
this footage to think that individuals
how many years out of slavery are now
owning oil wells that are producing
2,000 barrels a day is that not the
ultimate American dream is that not the
ultimate American story it flies in the
face of what I think some people
consider part of African American
history and culture and I think that
that was one of the things that Oklahoma
and what SS Jones is really kind of
showing is that that african-american
history and culture is not a monolith
and in a way it became kind of like a
marketing tool to encourage individuals
to migrate to move there that this is a
place where you can live you can thrive
and peacefully reside there were still
palpable racial tensions there are
lynchings there's Jim Crow segregation
there's all of these things and you
still have an african-american community
or many communities that really speak to
the fortitude and resilience of black
people in this country
you